squelettes visible un saut dans les airs
et tu termines en cendres voilà comment
on représente quelqu'un frapper par la
foudre dans les dessins animés et quand
on voit ce que ça fait sur un arbre
on se dit que ça doit pas être si loin
de la réalité mais ne serait-ce pas une
idée reçue si tu te faisais frapper par
la foudre que ressentiraient tu vraiment
quelles seraient ses chances de survie
et si tu ne veux pas que ça arrive que
faire en plein orage si tu es seul dans
une plaine en train de nager dans la mer
ou si tu assures toit des objets
métalliques comme ton portable je fais
quand même pas le jeter vous allez voir
il y a beaucoup d'idées reçues sur ce
que ça fait de se faire frapper par la
foudre quelle est la pire façon de se
faire foudroyer responsa déjà voici
l'homme le plus chanceux fumée
malchanceux du monde il se fait frapper
une fois et se relève et bim deuxième
fois il se relève et bim troisième fois
où je crois que vu un peu en réalité il
ya de grandes chances que cette vidéo
soit fric on survit rarement un impact
direct avec un éclair regardez-moi la
puissance du truc
ça a même décapité la tour eiffel en
1902 exploser des centaines de clocher
rien qu'en france on parle d'une onde de
choc équivalente à plusieurs centaines
de kilos tnt tu vois la prise électrique
juste à côté de toi elle fait 230 volts
et 16 ampères on est d'accord il n'a
aucune envie d'y mettre les doigts et
bien un éclair ça peut monter à
plusieurs centaines de millions de volts
et des dizaines de milliers dentaire et
ça c'est la moyenne un super bolt les
éclaire les plus puissants jamais
calculé peuvent se compter en milliers
de milliards de volts rassure toi sur
les 240 mille accidents de faux d'euros
chaque année seuls 5 % sont des impacts
directs car oui il ya trois autres
façons de se faire foudroyer d'abord les
éclairs latéraux 30 % des cas c'est
quand un endroit se fait toucher
directement et que des plus petits
éclairs ont bondi jusqu'à toi ensuite
les coups de foudre par contact 15%
d'état dans cet exemple les clercs
frappe le toit de l'enclos et voyage
jusqu'à la barre métallique pour faire
du steak grillé malheureusement ça
arrive souvent près des fils barbelés où
les vaches regroupe même dans votre
maison où vous vous croyez protéger les
clercs peut remonter les canalisations
on a eu des gens foudroyé pendant qu'il
faisait la vaisselle quand il prenait
tranquillement leur douche est même en
train de poser une pêche sur les
toilettes la dernière façon de se faire
foudroyer c'est plus de 50 % des cas les
coups de foudre par tension de pas en
gros tu est touché par la décharge
électrique dans le sol et ça peut aller
jusqu'à 80 mètres autour du point
d'impact ce carnage de 323 rennes en
norvège c'est pas des éclairs qui les
ont frappés un parent en c1 est clair
qui s'est propagée dans l'herbe humide
ça peut arriver pendant un match de foot
comme ici en colombie heureusement aucun
mort aucun blessé ou alors quand tu es
en train de nager
d'ailleurs quand j'étais petit je me
demandais pourquoi quand un éclair
frappé l'océan tous les poissons du
monde ne mourrai pas eh bien le sel
étant un bon conducteur l'éclair va
rapidement se dissiper particulièrement
surface donc situé à quelques mètres du
point d'impact
tu vas y passer mais les poissons en
profondeur bas ils sont tranquilles
c'est pour cette raison qu'il est aussi
dangereux d'aller sous un arbre vous
pouvez être frappé par un éclair latéral
par contact avec le bois ou par la
décharge dans le sol ça on va en
reparler qu'est ce que tu ressens quand
un éclair de frappe figurez vous que
beaucoup de gens témoigne n'avoir rien
senti et pour cause ils se sont
instantanément évanoui d'autres parlent
d'un coup de marteau piqueur dans les
danses de picotement extrêmes comme sidi
milliers de fourmis envahissait le
record de l'impression d'avoir de la
lawe fondu au milieu du ventre et muscle
ce paradis d'un coup tes yeux sans
valise d'une lumière blanche le temps
semble s'arrêter chaque témoignage est
différent et pour cause ça va dépendre
du point d'impact de la puissance de
l'éclair et comment il va voyager dans
ton corps si tu as de la chance et que
ta peau humide des clercs peu juste
circuler à la surface et vêtements vont
exploser en morceaux sous l'effet de la
vapeur et chaussures peuvent
littéralement volé haut de tes pieds et
comble du coup le tu peux te retrouver
avec ces espèces de cicatrices super
stylé des figures de lichtenberg
maintenant s'il est clair rendent dans
ton corps ça va faire mal tu auras un
point d'entrée et un point de sortie
généralement plus bas à des gens pour
qu'ils éclairent sort par le scrotum par
l'anus labo piqué pendant que l'éclair
est en toi il peut voyager n'importe où
ton sang et ton système nerveux ce sont
de bons conducteurs qui vont lui
permettre de se propager vers tes
organes vitaux ton coeur peut s'arrêter
l'air de tes poumons peut tellement
chauffé qu'ils explosent tu peux devenir
sourds ou avoir des dommages cérébraux
certaines personnes vont devenir folle
tout oublié de leur vie ou changer de
personnalité c'est le cas d'un
chirurgien qui est devenu pianiste
professionnel du jour au lendemain alors
qu'ils savaient pas jouer on a decade
d'éveil à la synesthésie août aveugle
qui retrouve la vue ça s'explique
simplement par le fait que la décharge
va littéralement robes août et le
cerveau est active et des hommes qui ne
devrait pas l'être d'ailleurs pour votre
culture tout ce dont on vient de parler
c'est de là qu'est rhône aux pathologies
la spécialité biomédicale qui étudie la
fulguration tenez à le caser parce que
rien qu'à le dire c'est trop stylé si ce
tableau clinique fait peur il faut
savoir que 90 % des gens touchés par la
foudre survivent mais 70% ont des
séquelles plus ou moins graves ça peut
être une cicatrice un bourdonnements
dans les oreilles un tremblement de la
main et aussi une paralysée à vie
comment savoir si la foudre va te tomber
dessus il y a trois signes qui doivent
alerter déjà l'odeur des éclairs car oui
ça sent quelque chose les molécules
d'oxygène sont déchirés par l'impact
formant de l'ozone est un gaz à l'odeur
piquante un peu chlorés qu'on associe
généralement l'électricité vous avez
forcément déjà senti ça et c'est pas bon
signe puisque ça veut dire que le vent y
donc l'orage viennent vers toi pour
estimer la distance qui dansaient par tu
connais l'astuce du flash
le son étant plus lent que la lumière tu
peux calculer le nombre de secondes qui
s'écoulent entre les deux plus
simplement dès qu'il ya un flash tu
comptes chaque seconde c'est 343 mètres
de distance au delà de trois secondes
l'orage et à plus d'un kilomètre mais ça
ne veut pas dire que tu es en sécurité
la foudre peut frapper jusqu'à 16
kilomètres du nuage d'orage on a même un
cas à 40 km il peut faire super beau
temps ciel bleu aucun nuage menaçant à
l'horizon et coup droit un tiers des
accidents se produisent d'ailleurs après
que laura choix pas ces gens sortent
tranquillou % que c'est terminé mais non
il faut que la distance entre le flash
et le son soit de plus de 25 secondes et
ses longs 25 secondes la situation
devient critique si tu commence à
entendre des petits craquements ou des
bourdonnement d'abeilles tuchan un goût
de métal dans ta bouche il y à de
l'électricité statique dans l'air il
faut que tous tes poils se dresse
soudain tu sembles voir une brume
fantomatique des petites flammes bleues
se forment sur tes objets mauvaise
nouvelle tu vas être frappé par un
éclair tués dans une zone de différence
de potentiel ce que tu vois là ce sont
des feux de saint-elme c'est
particulièrement visible sur les mâts
des bateaux pendant l'orage puisque ses
fins et en hauteur donc la cible des
éclairs l'explication est temps que les
charges positives sont attirés vers le
nuage se concentrant donc dans le point
le plus haut littéralement des aimants à
foudre si ça venait à arriver tu as
quelques secondes pour réagir
et on explique comment fin de vidéo
pourquoi il ne faut jamais aller sous un
arbre pendant l'orage
alors je vous rassure ils ont survécu
mais vous voyez que ça protège 0 l'arbre
ça conduit bien l'électricité donc pas
ça va rebondir sur vous ou se diffuser
dans le sol dans le meilleur des cas tu
finis brûlés ou avec une broche qui
tombe dessus rauf en fait les éclairs
sont de gros flemmard ils vont
généralement viser le point le plus haut
car le plus court entre le nuage
insolent et si souvent les arbres les
building du coup si vous avez le malheur
d'être dans une plaine avec rien qui
dépasse à des kilomètres à la ronde il
ya deux grandes chances que ça tombe sur
vous comme c'est le cas dans de nombreux
accidents de bâches on dit que la foudre
ne frappe jamais deux fois le même
endroit à ses faux seins en fait les
éclairs ne tombe pas par hasard il
commence par envoyer des espèces de tête
chercheuse dans toutes les directions
ici elle loupe l'immeuble mais dès qu'un
endroit est en contact donne tout
l'éclair se concentre il ya même des cas
où l'éclair sort du sol attiré par le
nuage tu es littéralement foudroyé par
la terre heureusement c'est rare faut-il
jeter des objets métalliques pendant un
orage voilà une sacrée idée reçue non le
métal n'attire pas la foudre pensez-y on
parle d'un nuage de vingt mille mètres
de haut qui s'étend sur plusieurs
kilomètres et tu aimes faire croire que
c'est la fermeture éclair de ton sac à
dos il va faire une cible non comme on
l'a vu un orage décide de ce qui va être
frappés grâce à des têtes chercheuses la
première chose qu'ils croisent lee
concentrons à toute sa force et c'est
généralement un point en hauteur c'est
pour ça qu'on angleterre 1 foudroyé sur
cinq est un golfeur pas à cause du métal
de leur club mais parce qu'il le mette
en hauteur dans des hommes généralement
plate et ça marche aussi avec les
parapluies il est par contre vrai que le
métal conduit la foudre et qu'il est
dangereux d'en avoir sur soi si un
éclair frappe ça va glisser jusqu'à ton
bracelet qui va chauffer au point de
fondre voire de se valoriser là bas les
brûlures sont désastreuses le pire
objets apportés étant probablement les
écouteurs comme ceux des ipod car ce
sont des chemins que prennent la foudre
pour frapper directement le visage et de
faire exploser les oreilles tout ça
m'amène à vous parler d'un petit
paradoxe pensez vous qu'un chevalier en
armure métallique au milieu d'un orage
est quelqu'un en danger
figurez-vous que non pas tant que ça et
ce grâce au principe de la cage de
faraday l'électricité va préférer
parcourir ce qui est le plus conducteur
donc autour de l'objet en métal ont
corps n'étant que du second choix bien
sûr il faut que la rumeur soit assez
épaisses ne touchent pas ta peau que
toutes les plaques sera lui ensemble et
qu'elles sont en contact avec le sol
mais si vous avez tous réunis vous
pouvez faire comme ce type et jouer avec
des éclairs avec une simple cotte de
maille c'est grâce au principe de la
cage de faraday qu'une voiture ou un
avion pourtant métal sont de bons
endroits où se réfugier personnellement
un éclair mais déjà tombé dessus en
voiture et j'ai rien eu je pensais que
c'était les pneus qui avaient absorbé la
foudre mais pas du tout si le caoutchouc
et bien un isolant à faible voltage ça
sert à rien face à la puissance de la
foudre c'est la cage de faraday qui m'a
sauvé l'électricité a enroulé la voiture
en s'évacue ensuite vers le sol comment
survivre à un éclair malgré toutes vos
précautions vous est pris au milieu d'un
orage pendant votre donné qu'un abri à
l'horizon et vous savez que les arbres
sont une mauvaise idée soudain les
signes annonciateurs bourdonnement
électricité statique et feu de synthèse
vous êtes la cible des cieux
contrairement à l'idée reçue inutile de
sauter l'éclair a voyagé plusieurs
kilomètres depuis les nuages c'est pas
les quelques centimètres qui te sépare
du sol qui vont faire la différence neut
allonge pas non plus puisque une plus
grande surface de ton corps sera exposé
en cas d'impact au sol et
particulièrement des organes vitaux
évite aussi d'avoir les jambes écartées
car les clercs va rentrer par une jambe
pour ressortir de l'autre mais en
traversant ton corps au passage dans le
meilleur des cas le courant passe
directement d'une jambe à l'autre et
tout finit juste avec les coucougnettes
briller non en l'absence d'abri il n'y a
qu'une seule bonne façon passer un orage
tu dois tu as croupir en position
foetale les jambes bien serré en levant
les talons pour avoir le moins de
contacts possibles avec la terre si
possible mais un isolant au sol comme
ton manteau ciré ou tapis de yoga
protège ta nuque entre la tête pour
éviter qu'elle soit découvert c'est bien
la dernière zone que tu veux voir à le
frapper ok c'est pas confortable mais tu
aurais dû grandement des chances d'être
touchée la chaîne du monde de jamie
avait testé expérimentalement cette
méthode avec un orage article elle et ça
marche du tonnerre en cas d'impact sur
un ami va tout de suite le secourir
contrairement à l'idée reçue sera pas
électrique le corps n'est pas une
batterie de stockage éteint les flammes
pour éviter les brûlures appelle les
secours et fait lui un massage cardiaque
pour démarrer son coeur n'essayez pas de
le relever parce que l'éclair a peut
être explosé certains de ses os plus de
cent personnes sont foudroyés chaque
année en france ça paraît peu mais sur
la totalité de ta vie et par rapport à
la population française ça fait une
chance sur huit mille quatre cent que ça
arrive un jour plus précisément une
chance sur quinze mille trois cents
selon le national weather service
américain ça veut quand même dire que
parmi tous nos abonnés vingt à quarante
d'entre vous allez vous faire démonter
par la foudre et quand on regarde les
statistiques on est pile dans la cible 1
80% des gens frappés par la foudre sont
des hommes et or en partie des jeunes de
20 à 30 ans vous êtes les prochains non
je rigole c'est cool leur âge moi ça me
donne envie de dormir et puis la foudre
va déjà frôlé deux fois donc
statistiquement super nord non faudra
demander ça rouille sullivan qui s'est
fait frappé sept fois dans toute sa vie
la probabilité que ça arrive a été
calculé vraiment il aurait dû jouer au
loto n'hésitez pas à nous raconter vos
histoires si vous avez déjà croisé la
foudre on épinglera les meilleurs
témoignages merci de nous avoir suivis
penser à liker et partagez aller les
amis
[Musique]